well I just came out of the Metro and
there were a lot of sirens going off
people were shouting and running and we
were told to get off the street so
that's what we did now we're here in in
a home of people had a having a beer and
just like waiting here what what
happened what I understand that you were
told to get off the streets
yes people told us there was gunfire
multiple guns we're here we're hurt and
people told us it's not safe get off the
freezer right now did you actually hear
that that gunfire do you see what was
going on as he came out of that metro
exit no we just came out after it
happened but the stop before the metro
stops we got of people were like yelling
and shouting like leaves the metro but I
but I don't pick French so I yeah didn't
get off but you are safe now yes I hope
so what was the atmosphere I'm kind of
tense I've never been in a situation
like this but people here it's very
close to Charlie Hebdo people that live
here kind of have been through this so
that much the atmosphere is kind of
people are having a beer watching TV and
is waiting what's going to happen